hi I'm Jim Gaffigan and I'm going
undercover on the Internet
can you believe it don't tell anyone but
it's actually me Wow
Laura you know what's so great about
quarry it's like you know we should have
a quorum about this
how does Jim Gaffigan treat his fans
well there's three and so those three
fans they'll get flowers on their
birthday I'll send them notes like hey
just checking in you know I'll send them
stationery Jim Gaffigan fan club it's
fan a thing is it a fan I think people
are fans of like Beyonce or are Kelly
sand
should I take my nine-year-old child to
see comedian Jim Gaffigan perform yeah I
would say that at my shows it is new
material so like if your nine-year-old
only wants to hear old material they
might be disappointed but I you know
there's plenty of kids that are very
kind of sophisticated with their humor
taste how did David Letterman help Jim
Gaffigan career look he's my dad so
that's probably some of it but like he
definitely did help me and his executive
producer Rob Burnett because they kind
of gave me a certain seal of approval in
that if Letterman thinks somebody's
funny then maybe they're funny because
the entertainment industry is filled
with cowards that don't have opinions
how does Jim Gaffigan produce so much
content magic it's very selfish
motivation coming up with a new Joe is
really rewarding and also I try and
produce so much content because I'm
trying to get my dad to like me what was
Jim Gaffigan like in high school I went
to a very small high school it was 120
students there weren't the traditional
roles in my high school like a John
Hughes film of like the jock and the
pothead and the bully and all that so
because it was such a small school
everyone did everything so I
was an athlete I tried really hard
studied hard and then only got like B
pluses I was voted funniest I was also
voted best male body I mean I didn't
look like this but I was in pretty much
pretty good shape back then I mean that
was this is like the 1800s so Twitter
seriously it's actually me
I wonder if Jim Gaffigan gets along with
raunchy comedians I mean how does one
trade hooker stories for pizza stories I
do have many friends that are filthy or
irreverent if someone has a raunchy
story it's not like they only do raunchy
things like they'd still have to go to
the store there crafts people working on
their art which is stand-up and
sometimes that involves a hooker I guess
sad Wikipedia what about this it's
actually me Gaffigan style is largely
observational and it's principal topic
relate to laziness eating and Parenthood
yeah you know it's not like I only think
of jokes about laziness or Parenthood
why do you need to put me in a box in
there I mean just because I'm
good-looking doesn't mean I can't act
sometimes in interviews don't realize
all your stand-up is all about your kids
and I'm like it's not really it's hard
to be me I can't believe I even have a
Wikipedia page also during his routines
he was sometimes perform soliloquies you
know cuz I'm like Shakespeare by using a
high-pitched voice in the third person
deliver negative feedback on his own
performance such as after making a
diarrhea joke in his 2012 special mr.
universe using the voice I this is
literally what's written please if you
know how to read or write can you update
my Wikipedia page still in the same
sentence using his voice and saying
really he's using diarrhea jokes he
calls that voice his connection with the
audience first of all I don't call it my
connection with the audience but that's
right
I call it my inside voice I am trying to
vocalize
what I believe an audience member might
be thinking at the time so if I'm
talking about horses and I've done six
minutes on that I could speak for the
audience and gentle-like
that's got to be the end of the horse
jokes I never even wanted to hear two
minutes of horse jokes so it makes them
a participant in it
submit he is also regarded as a clean
comic using little profanity in his
routines I mean that's just no comedian
wants any other adjectives except for
funny clean comedian yeah am i clean
compared to some of my friends yes am i
good-looking yes and by the way I would
also say it's about authenticity so we
all have that friend that curses
ridiculously unnecessary amounts but
it's authentic to them where it's not
authentic to me because Jesus told me
not to next as of June 2016 Gaffigan was
the most popular comment on all of
Pandora calm with over six hundred and
forty seven million spins
I didn't six have 47 million I don't
know if that's true I mean hopefully
that's true that's amazing but like with
streaming audio services stand-up has
changed so dramatically from when you
know I started and you know I know that
you know I have a special in Amazon and
I have some specials on Netflix but the
streaming service the audio streaming
services are amazing at getting people
exposed to your stand-up reddit it's
actually me like anyone's dying like is
it him no heckling Jim Gaffigan and
louis c.k two great shows both on top of
their game
I was surprised however at all the under
no circumstances no heckling at any time
else will eject you from the venue is
this the new thing or just a local
Midwestern thing first of all is that
what you're going to a show you're like
oh I I went to the stand-up show and I
wanted to ruin the show by heckling and
then they have these rules I don't you
know I don't make any amount
been on that that might have been the
venue and I don't consider I mean I've
performed in Omaha many times and it's a
perfectly fine audience I don't know why
that would come up and like were they
things were draped over rows and rows of
chairs you know like they have a rain
delay on baseball and they put like a
tarp out what if when the audience came
in there was a tarp that said no
heckling is that what you encountered
next what are your thoughts on the dad
bod craze is it true I don't think it's
true like I feel like we try and make
things good that aren't good like dad
bods yeah
when everyone's like a known once dad
once I am DP you may not believe it or
not care but it's actually me has said
that he dislikes being labeled as a
family-friendly comedian here's what I
dislike about the term family-friendly
it usually means bad family friendly
restaurants family friendly hotels
through it all so like I don't want to
be lumped in with the water parks
because by the way I have kids and I
have to go to water parks and they're
brutal
his comedy career began after a friend
that him to do stand-up comedy well it
was a dare but yes that is true because
I was somebody who was a coward I didn't
want I wanted to do it but I was like I
grew up in a small town in Indiana and I
didn't think that it was something that
I could do I thought it was just fancy
people on these coast or the west coast
that did it boom Instagram thinking of
baby number six no I have five kids I
love most of them no I love them all if
my wife got pregnant I wouldn't be like
I'm out of here I would obviously open
my exhausted fat arms to any gift that
was given to us because I would hate to
be too negative and then we do have a
six kid and then the kid looks and sees
this and they're like and then they have
to show their therapist which
probably at that time will be a robot
what if like in the future
you had like this robot that went around
your apartment you're like all right
switch into therapist mode and then and
then you're like alright switch into sex
robot mode
I'm not saying I would do this I'm
saying you would not me clean my
apartment stuff like that I'm just
saying I don't I don't know if I need
any more kids posted that's it
I'm signing off the internet forever
until later on wouldn't be great if I
just threw up right now